Express three-five-two-five, taxi to position runway 6 Left.
To position 6 left, Express 3525.
Citation Bravo 77, contact Tower on 118.9.
Good day.
Tower on 118.9 for Citation Bravo 77.
The Citation crew is behind schedule and in a hurry to take off.
Because of this, they've misheard their taxi instructions.
Instead of taxiing to the end of Six Left,...
...they believe they're to cross Six Left and proceed to Six Right.
They're approaching a midpoint intersection and are about to enter the active runway.
The tower controller has landing traffic, and wants to expedite Express 3525's take-off.
Tannair 79, continue number one for runway six left, traffic on the roll.
Express 3525, winds 070 at six, cleared for take-off, Runway Six Left.
Cleared for take-off runway Six Left, Express 3525.
Tower, Citation B77 with you on taxiway Delta for Six Right.
Citation B77, say again your position!
Is this Citation on Delta or Charlie?
He's on Delta at Six Left!
Citation B77, stop!
Hold your position.
Hey! Tower! We just missed a small jet on Six Left!
Tannair 79 pull up and go around, traffic on the runway.
Citation B77, exit runway Six Left immediately.
Fortunately, Express 3525 is able to lift off and clear the Citation.
Had it not, history has taught us that the outcome could have been deadly.